okay uh
this is the answer for you
um
I will phrase the question a little
differently though
what is
the architectural elements of the throw
okay or
what is the geometry being generated
that leads to
a fall
okay
uh this here represents
spine in koku home
okay
can I have one person get this horse
line
this is the head part
this is the pelvis part
and this is the feed part
yet please
give it back to zero okay
[Music]
um
a person is going to be brought into the
technique
and then with what what you can call
osensei's Yin yield
they'll get a tilt
you want their spiders to tilt so their
spine's not like this their spine is
going to tilt okay
their forward progress
is represented by
this energy line pulling go ahead a
little dot okay
come back to neutral
okay
what I am going to do on this tilt is
get another
uh triangle shape in once I enter
okay so I am going to put the leg here
and I am going to send the feet
in that direction go back go back go
back go come back
I'm going to send the feet in that
direction by capitalizing upon the
inertial pull of his Center my Ed me
goes
that way
making his feet
do that
stop
okay and you'd be pulling a little
here
what this does stop right there and just
stay there taunt yours please make good
time
this creates where you see that head is
going to start falling this way okay
Road and handle
here's where this arm is working
okay
and he's now
spinning
this way
do you see
okay so if I have this energy here
you're going to pull yours that way
you're going to pull yours straight and
you're going to pull yours wait till I
say go ready go
and this is what happens okay now
he's parallel to the ground do you see
and when I say let go
let go got it one two three let go
and the guy falls
okay
so a couple things
we have to figure out how to get the
tilt
right because that was the start of it
all
and we have to figure out
how to keep his energy going forward
we have to understand
how to keep his feet going forward but
at another angle to his Center
and we have to have it so that his head
is going backwards
but it's not from my arm
pushing her backwards he goes before
that
okay and I'll show you where those three
forces are in the technique okay as far
as what you touch
it's not relevant whatever you're
touching that's the pattern so I might
be on the front of his face on his
throat I'd never be on the chest though
that's too much mass I want to be at the
extremity of the spine so that's going
to be somewhere on the face I don't care
if he's looking in straight up down it
doesn't matter okay as far as the leg
goes I don't care either where I am on
the leg uh it has a lot to do with his
height my height and things like that I
just need the stance to go one way that
had to go the other way
okay
so first let's deal with the Tilt and
their forward progress how do I do that
I called it osense
okay
his uh spine is coming in by
prescription
and I want to move him in a way that I
have forward energy but he starts to
tilt he just starts to tilt that's all I
need that's all you need it doesn't have
to be a big thing
and it's not back
he tilts
so maybe over here
he comes in and there's your tilt there
uh I'll demonstrate the forward progress
by having him pull
he's not pushing
okay so he's pulling me he's pulling me
okay and I'm Brown you see and this
thing's making him move forward making
him move forward and into itself
I'm not just getting out of the way and
he leans his head in that's not what
happens
okay
um
his body is very segmented
the Joe is not segmented
this is where the internal aspect comes
in
so uh as he pulls
I unify his body
and I can make it go where I want
I'm not just getting out of the way
let's have you push I'm not just getting
out of the way
and then culturally expect him to lean
into me that's not what's happening
from here
I I'm going to manipulate his whole body
his whole body is moving
that's the forward progress
the backwards progress
comes from the second spiral I'm going
to make with my hand
[Music]
so my hand did the
our spiral in essence but I'm now going
to do the inward spiral
and you want to pay attention to the
Elbow of the Airborne spiral that
elbow's going back
so as he's stuck here
and I go up and that's what starts the
backward progress
so here's the Tilt and forward boom and
then that's where he's going backwards
here's where I enter
okay
I'll just get in the final position
here's where my edema is
and then I spin him
right his head oh
his head's gonna go that way around me
it does not matter let's say he uh
he he turns his head away
it doesn't matter I still have that
motion and hint
let's say hey let's stop
so I'm on his throat doesn't matter
still work the same thing
[Music]
same thing on
um
okay you move in here's the tilt
right there
so you get the tilt
head
stats goes that way a nurse is going
that way
on the entry
he's already falling
he's already falling here
you don't need that
to push him down
you're just keeping him in the throwing
geometry
pull it off
again you don't need that part
almost dead
you don't need it
he's already falling you're aiming him
can you see the
Joe
you must resist the temptation
to accelerate him backwards Remember The
Stance and the center are going forward
okay
the head goes backwards well because
he's going forward so you can you add
his body moving forward
with the inward spiral elbow on his head
holding it in place okay
you you must if you wouldn't mind from
here
you must resist
trying to bring him up
and then
accelerate them
you want to turn him
with a body block
okay so when I'm internal his whole body
moves with me his whole body moves but
somebody that has a lot of resistance
they're going to lock their body they're
not gonna
Bend okay so for example I I could have
Superior mechanics with my anchored
elbows leverage okay and once I go here
now he locks his body don't let your
poor bit
you're not gonna get that to move
do you understand
but you will get it to turn
so he'll lock his stomach
he's locking his stomach so he can't
bend backwards
and bend backwards he's stopping off
he's going to be tense got it when we
tell Tim
he's hands now he's spinnable
okay
so we'll just uh nope I'll get you
there's the tilt lock your body don't
bend backwards okay now he's spinning
don't worry I just want that out of the
place so now he's spittable
you understand you see that
so people coming in fast people
resisting they do not Bend at the waist
but they are spinnable and spinnable is
what you're doing your your Aikido
nagawasa you're not bending people
backwards and stuff like that okay
the technique is Coke you hope not
cooking
that means it is a cultivation drill for
developing Coq hole that means it is
more oriented towards the energetic
component of my art of my practice okay
if you pay attention again reminding you
you have only two arm movements in
Aikido kimono you'll have
the outward spiral
and it's inverse the inverse spiral
out
in water
young fire
what you're doing in this Kokyo Hall
is both spirals with one hand
so
here is going to be
I know it looks like I'm going in but
it's actually the outward spiral
so I'm doing the hour spiral
then I do the inward spiral it's right
here
so in one technique you're reconciling
in a non-fire water
and your dust rotating the tandem fields
on that rotating cross pattern that we
mentioned in a few videos ago all in one
technique okay so you want to make sure
you do that
which makes it energetically incorrect
to go here because that's not one of
those spirals it's not working the Tom
denfield okay
so
whoa
if you take him out of it
I go in here
and I'll exaggerate the time then
okay but all that's internal
that's your ritual
that gets that rotating tandem field is
what I do to him internally I rotate his
internal condom feel
rotate his internal content
making this
wrong
that's just crap okay
let's try it again
so for you you all here I kind of
slipped by you but I'm just doing energy
work and the other hand is is part of
the energy work okay so in up to here I
was just showing the mechanics right the
architecture uh yesterday with a
demonstration I'm just going to do the
energy work and you pick up what you
want okay so as uh this hands come here
I would like for you to pay attention to
this hand okay so this hand is headed up
then we'll go down missing
couldn't watch last night's video and
you'll see that happen pop down okay
so I'm over here
you are watching this hand right now
okay we already talked about it so come
on this one
well
until it goes back in
doesn't change here the stripe is the
Edward spiral
this way then pull them down
so this is the outer spiral this is the
inner spiral and they're going to trade
places
[Music]
foreign
that's where this hand is it's in the
way
when this hand is here the sand is in
the bottom
then they trade places
do you understand
what if we pay attention to the other
hand
it's doing like my demonstration this is
dead
okay try it again